[Music]
no tell me friend have you heard the
good news
oh no I I'm not just [ __ ] with you
Jesus doesn't give a [ __ ]
fox searchlight pictures invites you to
meet a man well that you're such a
beautiful she needs to leave who wants
the world to accept him my wife left me
17 years ago I just need to move on find
somebody new not you necessarily in the
worst possible way working man a 40
years from now you're gonna be on your
deathbed saying where did it all go how
did we end up like this
[Music]
there's a lot of seats you know in this
train
[Music]
vicious who looks like your ex-wife put
this girl up for adoption 17 years ago
yeah that's life how could you not tell
me that we had a daughter excuse me do
you think I could get this with the
aioli on the side as I requested yeah I
think you should know we have tickets to
wicked
hey [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up can't you
see that this woman is having a profound
moment I said that liar you tell me that
you don't want to see your daughter we
want to do stalkers it may seem and
Claire Jenny Craig's over here you need
to shut the [ __ ] up you if you're
wondering about the lack of family
resemblance she used to be a real hippo
hey myself
[Music]
yeah Eddie meal unfit is in the same
instant family you guys are so beautiful
and I can't deny it
my ex she's a good one I just have to
hug her embrace her maternal nature
sorry I can't help you with that in that
case I guess I'll take a blow job in I
am I should have brought my wallet that
is quite a tattoo how's that it's like
the ultimate argument in der like no I
don't want your [ __ ] job I want to
destroy your entire society face with
the love of her life
mother [ __ ] Fleming's are in the
house
yes oh my god [ __ ] yeah looks like he
works out quickest step